terres du son est multiple vers du son
et électro en la matière thylacine du
d'hier soir une très belle découverte
il est seul qui fascine avec ordinateur
percussions électroniques et saxophone
seul est libre de créer les vagues qui
vous rassurent fait
avant les composites à l'ancienne
c'était des mecs qui composaient tout
seuls dans leur coin avec un piano donc
au final on retrouve on retourne à
quelque chose comme ça avec des musiques
électroniques qui nous permettent
d'avoir accès en fait alors qu elle se
complaît moi c'est vraiment comme ça que
je le vois je pense que je fais de la
musique électronique parce que c'est ce
que j'ai sous la main un peu c'est ce
qui est le plus pratique pour moi si
j'avais un banquet sous la main je pense
que j'en ferai quelque chose aussi je me
serais là dessus plus anachronique les
rollers 79 échappé d'un clip de new
order
on s'y croirait dans cette new wave un
peu froid des années 80 s'il n'y avait
les baskets du chanteur
parlons gare d'europe tant qu'on n'y ait
perdu son empreinte à woodstock sa
liberté vestimentaire
venez comme vous êtes n'est pas ici un
slogan démago il prend son sens naturel
dans le contexte d'une fête populaire
décomplexée à la nuit tombée le festival
a sorti son grand font pas d'extrait du
live pour les caméras les membres du
groupe veulent l'ombre en pleine lumière
bilan de cette deuxième journée beaucoup
de gens heureux
les yeux brillants par forcément à cause
du jus d'orange sûrement l'effet de la
musique oui bien super boulot à 16
heures les coupures de son c'était
génial
une chaleur à crever mais une ambiance
de folie
j'aime bien parce que c'est très
diversifié entre la scène électro jazz
rock c'est vrai c'est yahia ce qu'il
faut pour tout le monde parce qu'on
pourrait faire de mieux c'est toujours
un peu plus de prévention sur la gestion
des déchets notamment les mégots il y en
a un petit peu partout oui faudrait
améliorer les choses et profitable aux
alcools d'accueil beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont déjà tous alcoolisés et des moins
jeunes et des moins jeunes